throughout the pandemic
athletes have been the most tested
population on the planet
sometimes providing examples of emerging
theories about covet 19
and as countries around the world
continue to fight back covet 19
attention has turned to tokyo where the
olympics are underway
one challenge some athletes are facing
testing positive for the virus
despite having been vaccinated this
isn't the first we've heard of this
what are the chances of getting covet 19
after
receiving a vaccine well you get a
better chance at buying a winning
lottery ticket
but it happened to warriors player
damien lee he will be out at least two
weeks
it was not a false positive as first
thought even though wallman
had been vaccinated yankees gm brian
cashman
says three players tested positive and
three others are likely infected
about 85 percent of the team is
vaccinated
including those who have the virus these
examples are known as breakthrough
infections which occur when someone
tests positive for covid19
at least two weeks after getting their
final shot do these breakthrough cases
mean the vaccines are failing no the
vaccines are not failing the vaccines
are working extremely well
and as expected they do protect the
majority of recipients from
severe disease that's what vaccines are
designed to do
prevent death and severe disease but
most vaccines including those created to
fight covet 19
don't completely protect you from
infection so it's not all that
surprising that breakthrough infections
are showing up
as of july 12th more than 159 million
people in the u.s
have been fully vaccinated cdc data
suggests just under 5500 have had
breakthrough infections
resulting in hospitalizations or deaths
that's one in approximately 29 000
people who have been vaccinated
breakthrough infections are something
that we want to monitor
but in terms of their overall influence
in the pandemic they play a much smaller
role
than transmission among people who
haven't vaccinated
but these cases raise questions about
our immunity to the virus
and hint at a future in which it isn't
gone completely and we learn to live
with it
that's due in part to variance research
shows that variants
including delta can partially evade the
immune response from prior infection
and vaccination we mount a really good
immune response
against the virus that our body is
trained to recognize
your body is really good at recognizing
and neutralizing
those specific threats but when the
virus starts to change
sometimes it doesn't recognize the virus
as well and so that's how you sort of
see it chip away at that immune response
that's one of the reasons that health
officials are really sort of concerned
about this
global vaccination drive in order to you
know prevent the virus from spreading
both to saves lives and to prevent it
from further mutating and evading the
immune response
the delta variant is the most contagious
version of the virus to be identified
but research suggests that full
vaccination is still protective against
severe disease
and death the outcomes that have made
kova 19
so devastating what dictates whether
someone is more likely to get infected
even if they're vaccinated dr hatsuyanu
says there are four main variables
first is the amount of virus that is
circulating in your community
so if a great number of people around
you are infected
then the possibility of you getting
exposed obviously increases
if you're in close proximity with people
that are infected particularly those
that are unvaccinated and have generally
higher viral loads then the probability
of you getting infected increases
the second is tied to vaccine uptake so
if a large
portion of the population is vaccinated
then
your virus transmission virus loads
everything decreases so the chances of
spreading the virus amongst this
population obviously decreases
that's because vaccinated people act as
a kind of shield
even when they do get infected a recent
cdc study found that vaccinated people
carried less virus
and potentially didn't spread it as much
as unvaccinated people
cases were also shorter and less severe
vaccines helped create a kind of immune
memory of what a virus looks like
helping the body fight it off more
quickly when it spots it
that makes it harder for the virus to
spread overall roughly half of all
americans are fully vaccinated
but in some states and globally the
vaccination rate is much lower
giving the virus more opportunity to
spread and mutate
that's why having large gatherings like
concerts or the olympics
can be so challenging from a public
health perspective
third individual behavior matters so as
measures have been
abandoned such as masking and social
distancing
when you don't have a significant number
of the population vaccinated
then the ability of the vaccines to
protect you from getting infected
decrease finally even after vaccination
individual immune systems vary in their
ability to prevent and fight off
infection
older and immunocompromised people seem
to be more susceptible to breakthrough
cases and those tend to be more severe
that's why health officials are
considering additional doses
right now primarily for people who have
a
compromised immune system and might not
have produced a good immune response
after two doses of vaccine
breakthrough cases might be asymptomatic
or mild
so people may not know to get tested but
that's not the case for athletes
we're actually seeing breakthrough
infections happen a lot more
among sports teams like baseball or for
the olympics
because those are the people that get
tested pretty regularly even if they're
vaccinated at the olympics
organizers of the games are scrambling
to deal with a rising load of athletes
and officials who are testing positive
upon arrival in japan some with
breakthrough infections
the vaccination rates are low in japan
cases there are rising and organizers
didn't require those participating to
get vaccinated
dr hatsuyanu and many other experts
remain concerned that holding a
large-scale international event
prior to reaching a critical mass of
vaccinated individuals
has the potential to contribute to the
viruses spread around the world
the olympics is a special event and it's
truly remarkable that it brings all
these people from all these different
countries together
but it also poses a perfect ground
to mix variants and spread the virus
that will then go back
to each athlete's country